-Welcome back!
-Whoo! Whoo!
-Looking good.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Looking fantastic.
Band! What's up band?
-And let me tell you
another place --
Not only are you
looking fantastic in person,
you were on the cover,
with our friend Colin Jost,
on "New York Magazine."
That's the "New York."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's wonderful.
-Yay!
-Now, when you first saw that,
were you happy
right away when you saw it?
-No.
-Okay.
What didn't you like right away?
-Because there were -- You know
when you do a photo shoot,
they take all --
And I picked, like,
so many different pictures that
were, like,
so sexy and different.
And then they just
picked that one.
But after I looked
at it for a while,
I liked it because
it's very comical.
It's, like, a cute comical,
like Lucille Ball-ish kind of.
-Yeah, it really is.
-I like it.
-It's a great cover.
It's very memorable.
And I'm glad that
you came around on it.
-Yes.
-Something that was very
exciting for me this week --
you played Oprah on "SNL."
-Yes!
It was so fun.
My bracelet came off.
-It was so much fun,
your bracelet came off.
-My bracelet came off.
-I mean, that was the
first time that happened.
Was it exciting
when it came to pass?
-It was like last minute,
Colin text me
in the middle of the night.
He was like, "I want to write
something with you doing Oprah.
Are you down for it?"
And I was like, "Yeah.
You know, I want to do it."
I was scared that I wasn't
gonna get her voice right.
I really wanted to do her
justice, 'cause she is the bomb.
-You don't want to do
a half-ass Oprah.
-Right, right,
right, right, right.
-And did it feel --
Like, did you actually
feel empowered being Oprah?
-While they were doing my makeup
and putting everything on,
I just had her picture in front
of me and I just stared at her.
I just stared at her.
And you just get that
Oprah feeling.
Like, you know, she has
this chin, smile, fulfilling.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ As Oprah ] Hello!
-So, now -- You probably
had feelings beforehand,
but now you actually have
a personal investment in
Oprah running for president.
-She has to run, 'cause
I'll get an Emmy if she runs.
'Cause I will play her
to death, yes.
-Oh, that's good.
So now you have
another reason to root for her.
-Yes. Yes.
Go for it, Oprah!
I'll vote for you now!
-Another thing that was
very exciting about last week --
And it's always fun when
old cast members come back.
Our friend Fred Armisen
came back.
Bill Murray was there.
-Bill. Bill is always
a pocketful of fun.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-Bill's one of
those ones that --
You know, when he stopped by --
and it was only
a few times when I was there --
but you get a little bit nervous
because he was so good at it.
-I'm not nervous
around him anymore.
-Well, are you
nervous around anybody?
-No.
-I was gonna say.
-I do -- There
is a couple of people
that I'm probably gonna
lose my bleep for.
-Yeah.
-Definitely.
-Jennifer Lopez.
-Uh-huh.
-I'm definitely --
-Still haven't met her?
-Let me tell you.
Okay, so, I'm going
to Vegas to do a gig, right?
-Uh-huh.
-And I think I'm gonna get
to see Jennifer Lopez perform.
-Oh, you're gonna
go to her show in Vegas.
-Oh, my God.
I'm so excited,
'cause I literally am going to
change every time she changes.
I will be the loudest --
I'm gonna be like,
♪♪ Up on that floor ♪♪
-Oh, man.
I didn't know -- Is this a
longtime love affair with J-Lo?
-I love, love, love
Jennifer Lopez.
Ever since "Selena."
-Yeah. That's a long time.
-Yeah.
-You -- But, see, the thing
about you not being nervous,
'cause I -- You know, again,
I was at "SNL" for 12 1/2 years.
I don't have a single photo of
me with a host, a famous person.
-I don't know how you do that.
-I follow you on Twitter.
At every after party, they just
come in one after the other.
-I'm getting my picture.
-You took a picture -- Like,
I mean, again, needless to say,
I would never have the nerve
to even ask for this.
But you got
a selfie with Beyoncé.
-But look at my face.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Look at this.
Look at my face.
Okay, let me tell you something.
Every time I take
a picture with Beyoncé,
that's how my face looks,
because I'm always so scared
and then I'm always scared
that I can't ask her
for the picture over.
So all of my pictures
always look like
I got hit by a Range Rover
in the middle of it.
Like I didn't see
the Range Rover coming.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And It's funny because
you look like you didn't know
a picture was getting taken,
and you're taking the picture.
-I was like,
"Beyoncé, please just let me
get this one picture with you."
-I want to also
point out Beyoncé
having no trouble
at all with this photo.
Oh, she was so chill.
She was like,
"Girl, take the picture."
-Oh, my goodness.
I mean, that's one
worth having right there.
-That's my girl.